this video has been made possible thanks
to masterworks skip masterworks waiting
list by clicking on the link in the
description more about this in a bit
[Music]
i thought we would never live through a
war in the middle of the 21st century
how is this even possible i know i know
everyone has said this at some point in
the last few weeks everyone thought that
wars were a thing of the past it seemed
that john lennon's pacifis spirit had
possessed all of us europeans including
vladimir putin but remember john lennon
always meets yoko ono and the european
yoko ono moment was the invasion of
ukraine suddenly the anti-military
consensus of the european union has
disappeared we are entering a new era
with stories like this one
germany to boost military spending in
latest historic shift virtually all
european governments are making similar
announcements and yes this is a massive
shift in the european union europe has
been spending too little money on
defense for decades and when i say too
little money i mean less than it should
have under nato agreements according to
nato's founding charter all member
states should spend at least two percent
of their gdp on security however look at
this map
[Music]
the countries shown in red are those
that do not comply with nato commitments
as you can see with the exception of
france poland and a few others almost no
country has fulfilled their obligation
and this has been the case for almost 30
years in case anyone was wondering the
coronavirus has nothing to do with this
after the fall of the iron curtain all
european countries have reduced the
defense budgets year after year the
conclusion europe might have problems
deterring for example a possible attack
from russia or so it was thought because
as we are seeing in ukraine the point is
that all of this explains why vladimir
putin dared to invade ukraine while
expecting europe to stand idly by and
watch so the question now is where is
all the money going to come from to
finance this new military spending could
this be a golden opportunity for
european companies to what extent could
putin's threats be the unique
opportunity for europe to break and to
slide into stagnation today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
first we have a surprise for you and
this is all thanks to our sponsor
masterworks here on visualpolitik we
believe it is super important to stay
informed this implies to everything from
the political issues around the world to
your investment portfolio masterworks is
offering a lucky 25 people who sign up
using our link a free one-year
subscription to our latin politics
newsletter valued at 50 and as you
already know covers unique analysis of
latin american business and politics
masterworks the first and only art
investment platform allows investors to
buy shares that represent an investment
in iconic works by artists such as andy
warhol cause or banksy here's how it
works the masterworks research team
analyzes over 60 000 data points to find
financially attractive works that they
believe will appreciate and value then
masterworks acquires paintings ranging
from one million dollars to 30 million
and securitizes them by filing a public
offering with the sec no one can predict
the future and while past performances
is not indicative of future results
contemporary art prices have appreciated
in value by 14 for the last 25 years in
fact contemporary art prices outpaced
the s p 500 total return by 164 from
1995 to 2001. keep in mind that the art
market is not as liquid as the stock
market so you may have to wait a while
maybe even years until the painting is
sold skip the waiting list though by
clicking the link in the description you
can get started and manage your account
all online so go ahead and check it out
and as always in everything related to
investment tread carefully nothing is
risk-free and now let's get cracking
[Applause]
when we were pacifists
in 2018 donald trump threatened to pull
the united states out of nato had he
followed through on his threat nato
would have disintegrated at that point
and believe me many other world leaders
at that time would have celebrated
around that time the french president
emmanuel macron went so far as to say
that the state of nato was brain dead
at the moment i guess macron will be
wishing that no one reminds him of his
own words but you have to admit that at
that precise moment trump kind of had a
point you know that here on
visualpolitik we were always very
critical of the trump administration for
good reason but on this particular point
he gave an important wake-up call almost
no nato members were meeting their
military spending commitments at the end
of the day why should they they all knew
that in the event of a real threat they
could always count on uncle sam's
support for example in this graph you
can see germany's military spending
if you look at the 1960s germany spent
almost five percent of its gdp on
defense during the 1970s and 1980s this
expenditure went down to reach 2.56 by
1990. and just after 1990 that is when
the iron curtain fell it dropped
dramatically to just over one percent
and the same trend can be seen in almost
all other european countries so now the
question on everyone's minds is why did
all the europeans suddenly join hands
and start singing john lennon's imagine
while throwing their fate into the wind
well that might not be that exact
question but think about it why was nato
created why did the united states and
europe spend so much on armaments in the
1980s it's quite simple really because
there was a real threat in the soviet
union however with the soviet union
dissolved why spend more on weapons make
no mistake europe has had recent wars
millennials watching this video have
lived through at least one the balkans a
war in which nato ended up participating
however in the balkan conflict there was
no superpower with nuclear weapons
involved the great traditional wars seem
to thing of the past and after 9 11 the
new number one enemy and the free world
became terrorism suddenly the bad guys
in movies were no longer gentlemen like
this one they were more men like this
one throughout the 21st century all
defence forums started talking about new
concepts such as counter-terrorism cyber
security and hybrid warfare
[Music]
believe me when i say that this is not
just our opinion check out this survey
here you can see that the top military
priority for europe was north africa
followed by of course the middle east
think about it fighting a gang like
al-qaeda or daesh is a challenge but it
is a cheap challenge no need for
aircraft carriers no need for nuclear
submarines which is gear that is really
expensive for the armed forces in other
words very few thought that military
spending was necessary in fact some even
dared to say things like this
pedro sanchez the ministry of defense is
too large and the budget against poverty
is too little that's right for those of
you who don't know him pedro sanchez is
the prime minister of spain and yes it
is true that he said those words back
when he was still a candidate running
for election but it serves to illustrate
the general sentiment throughout europe
over the past 20 years european
governments have not only reduced their
military budgets they have also used the
military for tasks that have very little
to do with actual defense for example in
2005 spain created the military
emergency unit which is a kind of fire
department paid out for by the defense
budget and then there are entire units
that have stopped training for combat
and have moved on to humanitarian tasks
this is not a criticism of humanitarian
work by any means or indeed of first
responders you know that here on
visualpolitik we have a deep respect for
the armed forces and the important work
that they do
[Music]
but the facts are clear almost all of
europe has treated defense as if it were
kind of a joke we have even seen
outrageous proposals like this one
towards a climate-proof security and
defense policy a road map for eu action
that's right at some point someone in
brussels came up with the idea that
climate change should be a priority in
the armed forces now don't get me wrong
we are not saying that climate change is
not important it very clearly is but in
the case of war i mean really take a
second and imagine right now in ukraine
someone is buying bullets for their
machine guns and saying hey guys are
these ones biodegradable in other words
for more than 30 years the whole of
europe was convinced that there would be
no more war which now kind of sounds
ridiculous but let's be honest it sounds
ridiculous now that we have seen the
invasion of ukraine if we had posted
this exact same video just a couple of
weeks ago before the russian operation
many of you would have accused us of
being alarmists however everything has
changed putin has buried john lennon and
yoko ono and how did he do that well
we're gonna take a look at that right
now
[Music]
if you want peace be prepared for war
we have said several times in recent
days putin has already lost this war no
matter what happens in ukraine vladimir
putin's broader goal was to end the nato
threat for years it looked like he was
kind of gonna get away with it however
the invasion of ukraine has changed
everything check this out
neutral finns and swedes reconsider idea
of nato membership and that is just the
beginning the baltic countries have
already asked the united states to put
military bases in their countries and
take note it's not the united states
that said oh hey i would like to put
some military bases in estonia it's been
the estonian government itself that said
please put military bases here because
we're afraid of being next after ukraine
germany as we already mentioned has said
it's going to double as military
spending german chancellor olaf schultz
has gone so far as to say that he wants
to change the constitution to include
defence spending of 2 of gdp in other
words we have gone from listening to
john lennon to listening to sabaton
[Music]
[Applause]
the question now though is who's gonna
pay for the concert because it's very
easy to say let's spend more on defense
but what does that actually mean buy
more planes hire more soldiers well
let's see
german military still facing resources
shortage new report finds the report we
are talking about is not just any report
it is a report of the german parliament
which goes so far as to say that none of
the german submarines and combat
fighters are ready for you know combat
all of them are under repair or don't
have fuel to operate in other words if
russia were to attack there'd be no way
to respond at least not for several
weeks
and this is not unique to germany almost
all european armies have the same
problem what little weaponry they do
have is stored in hangars why because
maintaining a combat fighter to be
combat ready is expensive very expensive
and without money nothing can be done so
this is very likely to be one of
europe's first priorities of course new
equipment purchases are also to be
expected remember the f-35 fighter we've
talked about here so many times on
visualpolitik well it looks like we will
see many more f-35s in european armies
and make no mistake this is not due to
pressure from the united states this is
because after decades of meager budgets
europe has few weapons companies to
compete with the americans so as of
today if you want a state-of-the-art
fighter jet you have no choice but to
buy the f-35
wait a minute i know what many of you
are thinking especially those of you who
have come to this video from the
military affairs community of which
there are many of you you're saying
finally someone's listening and yeah
you're right but here comes the question
that no one is asking yet where is all
the money going to come to fund all this
think of it this way the list of urgent
life and death priorities and
existential emergencies in europe is
longer than ever two years ago we had
covered 19 which translates into more
taxes and more debt the recipe for
getting out of the covered crisis has
been the new green agenda to end the
climate emergency which means more taxes
and more debt now we also have the
threat of russia which will translate
into you guessed it more taxes and more
debt if we add to that the colossal
inflation that we are already
experiencing and will continue to
experience in the coming months we have
a pretty bleak outlook so the question
is what can be done well here we go with
an idea
kill two birds with one stone
[Music]
why is there no european google we've
asked this question a million times here
on visualpolitik and let's be clear this
is the problem for europe without
innovating and leading companies there
is no economic growth and without a
functioning economy there is no social
spending no fight against climate change
and no defense so the question is why
does europe always lag behind new
technological revolutions some will say
it's because europe has very high taxes
but if we compare country by country
estonia for example does not have higher
taxes than california legal certainty
well europe has legal certainty one of
the reasons for the lack of innovation
in europe is the military
[Music]
that's right the army or rather the low
investment in the armed forces of course
it is not the only reason nor perhaps
the most important one but it is still
relevant think about it this way israel
south korea and the united states are
technologically advanced countries
largely thanks to their militaries
silicon valley was born thanks to among
other reasons the fact that the military
established a telecommunications
development center right there
[Music]
in fact the internet was born as a us
defense project i know what many of you
are thinking really since when is the
state been so able to effectively to
promote r d we all know basically every
time a government wants to develop a
particular technology it kind of fails
miserably we see this happen all the
time for example the european union has
the horizon europe program which is
dedicated to funding research projects
on paper it's a fantastic idea but you
really don't want to investigate it in
depth i'll give you an example that we
have seen personally here at
visualpolitik we're not going to name
any names but believe me when i tell you
this is a real case
[Music]
in 2018 a university developed a system
to create a biomass press these are easy
to build presses that would allow
garbage to be compressed and turned into
pellets that generate energy in a very
efficient way the research was even
given a national award so what's the
problem the problem is it has been four
years since the completion of the
project it remains to be seen if a
biomass press based on the designs from
the project will ever be built not even
a patent has been taken out that another
company could buy it's a nice piece of
paper sitting on a shelf somewhere in
brussels after all who's going to bother
to turn this new technology into a
really useful product for society no one
no one has the incentive to do so and
there are thousands more examples just
like this one
military research and development on the
other hand is very different in this
case the states themselves have a very
strong incentive to create weapons which
compete with the enemy so r d is
channeled mainly to applied proposals of
course there are also big cost overruns
in defence research and development
there's the example of the f-35 which
we're given a good account of here on
visualpolitik but even in that case at
the end you get the most lethal fighter
jet available right now
[Music]
is it expensive yeah but it's a weapon
that is unrivaled at least as far as
anyone knows and many of the
technologies that have been developed to
create the f-35 will spawn a lot of
startups for civilian use put it another
way spending on defense has a civilian
utility therefore it is not at all
unreasonable that a large part of this
new military spending will not come from
new taxes but from other expenditure
items that were destined for civilian
research in other words the same funds
that now go to civilian projects may now
go to military projects that sooner or
later will have a civilian use
let's put this another way military
spending on innovation tends to be much
more applied than other public research
and development spending this is
precisely one of the reasons why israel
with a defense expenditure of 5.6 of its
gdp is also the nation of startups in
this case the military has served to
galvanize innovation in other sectors so
when it comes to spending military
research and development can reach
better results than any other option
and so now the question is over to all
of you are we going to see new tax hikes
in europe to pay for military spending
or will all this military spending come
from other spending items and to what
extent can the threat from russia be an
opportunity for the emergence of a much
needed european google one day you can
leave us your answer in the comments
below as always don't forget that here
on visualpolitik we have new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you